you ever seen somebody go from a very
dark place i mean a very very dark place
they're addicts
drug alcohol alcoholic dui after dui
after dui and
dwi and not good friends not in a good
place
boom three six 12 months later 24 months
later three five years later
they're in an incredible place fully
changed whole different human being
you don't even recognize them you watch
them you see their eyes you see the way
they walk
talk everything they do so impressive
what caused this by the way
let me give you the flip side you ever
seen somebody that's doing great
they're doing great things contributing
good family life they're in a good place
good surrounding making the right
decision
36 12 months later you don't recognize
them they're in a dark place what
happened to them
why are they not growing the way they
were growing before
this person same body same spirit
everything's the same
how is it so different of an attitude
and the results they're getting what
causes somebody to make drastic change
you ready
very simple for me words language
today i'm going to conference a couple
of my guys and one of my guys asked the
question he says
pat what do you think about burning out
you know what do you do when you're
working and your people are burning
out and just it's burn out and burn out
this and burn out that i said you know
what first of all i don't use that
phrase
i said how long you've been working with
a long time when's the last time you saw
me burn out i've never seen you burn out
i said i'm not a robot i'm not a machine
so you know how i slept last inside you
sleep last night i don't even know how i
slept last night
i pulled my head down i was gone
i woke up i don't even know what i
dreamt about i had slept so good i was
like
a thousand pounds on the bed going down
because i was gone i slept so good
i'm not telling you i don't rest not
telling you i don't rest
but i said i don't burn out why don't
you burn out okay let's talk about that
everything in life is about language
everything
there's a word i don't use i don't use
the phrase i was saying this on the
conference i don't use the phrase
i'm you see the t word it's one of the
most dangerous words in the world i
don't use the t
word i don't like to use the t word and
i don't like people using the t word
around me
very comfortable you said you know of uh
if you you use
whatever words you want to use around me
fine yeah
some of the stuff i don't like fine i
was in the military we
curse professionally we curse for a
living is what we do in the military
and that's stuck with me in works i've
done everything else i've done not
telling you i walk on water here
but i can't stand the t word why not
surround yourself with five people
around you let them keep telling me how
tea they are oh my gosh
what did you do oh my gosh i'm tired at
three o'clock i'm so
i need a nap i'm so tired oh my gosh you
driver be nuts
you're driving me nuts with this t word
you say it
you're right i don't want to say it i
don't want to say the t
word just like i don't want to say a lot
of words other words my dad was in town
i went home the tv was on the news was
on i can't even stand watching the news
right now
i like the news i enjoy seeing what's
going on
i want to be educated and aware of
what's going on with the economy in the
market today
but i read today i don't watch today
it's so divisive today
it's so manipulative today it's so
everything's about dividing today you
know when you run a a dana white
a dana white pits his guys against each
other for what
exposure competition bigger payday
people make more money right okay
espn you know cleveland
lakers bulls all these guys why because
it's results competition is great
there's nothing wrong with competition
in sports there's nothing wrong with
competition in
business there's nothing wrong with
competition in those types of areas
there's a lot of problems with
competition and politics you know why
because it's mindsets being injected
it's manipulation being injected
and many people are buying it long time
ago i refused to buy
a lot of different mindsets being
opposed to me both from my mom's side of
my dad's side i had people on my dad say
that would say
you know how women are they're all the
same they're all the same
they're all the same you know how
they're i said stop telling me
i don't want to hear that why not
i don't want to hear that i said because
one day i want to get married and have a
family i don't want to believe that
don't say it around me why are you
getting so upset because i don't want to
hear that
i don't want to hear it not around me i
don't want to hear it
on the other side let me tell you how
these types of people are
stop telling me how rich people are i
judge everybody based on how they are
i don't judge them by their wealth i
know poor people who treat me
royally and i know poor people that
treat me like [ __ ]
i know rich people that treat me with
respect and i know rich people that
don't
dollar sign never made a difference as
the character of the individual
stop putting that stuff in my mind i
don't want to hear it i was 21 years old
saying these things i was in the army
couple of guys telling me you'll never
be rich i don't want to hear it say to
somebody else
i worked at bally's a guy named jose was
one of my boss
why are you reading all these books i
can tell you exactly what book i was
reading at that time
what author i was reading i was 21 years
old you're wasting
time reading these books you're never
going to be a millionaire i said you can
say to yourself don't ever say that to
me again
i stop those thoughts i don't want it to
enter this mind
i don't i don't want to do it
you remember the scene my pursuit of
happiness you know that famous scene i
interviewed a real guy chris gardner
i introduced him at an event back in
0708 there's a scene
where he says don't let anybody change
your mind not including myself your
father
i don't want to do that the other day as
a father i made a mistake next to my son
talking to this couple and we're talking
about a third baby they're considering a
third baby
my son is next to me i said kids are so
annoying sometimes
i said it in front of him my son went
under the table
he wouldn't come up for 20 minutes my
heart my soul was crushed
i didn't like that all day i thought
about it
i went home i went to my son i said
we're leaving
my wife is he in trouble i said he's not
in trouble daddy's in trouble i said
we're leaving right now we're leaving
he says uh where are we going i said
well i gotta tell you something
he says is everything good i said
believe me everything's good but we
gotta go
i took him in the car we drove
i pulled over i said i want you to look
at me this is this a kid with a lot of
pride
very proud kid and i love this kid very
special kid
i said to him i said you know i said
something today and i noticed you didn't
like it
i said yes i said i want you to know
something
he says what's that i need you to look
at me my eyes he's looking at me my eyes
i said you know what was the greatest
day of my life
what the day you were born the greatest
day of my life obviously if i do you
have two other siblings
those were all also incredible days for
me but up until that point the greatest
day of my life was when you were born
i said i took you you stayed at the
hospital at jaundice we'd come and we'd
watch the light
your skin was yellow when you came home
after five nights i put you on my lap
we watched the super bowl that's when
you came home you were born february 1st
of 2012.
i was the happiest man alive because i
named my son patrick gabriel bet david
patrick is my name gabriel's your
grandfather's name
two people that's going to inject the
spirit into you and be david is the
house of david
beta a syrian last name bet david
i said you fulfilled me because god
god gave me the greatest gift ever was
my first son
let me tell you i've watched you since
the day you were born you've always been
very independent you've always demanded
respect
and what i said today was not a
responsible statement by your dad
i want you to tell me i want to explain
to you what i mean by this so you
understand this part he says what's that
i said here's what i mean by knowing i
said sometimes your daddy annoying yes
i said do i sometimes push you too hard
yes do i sometimes challenge you
yes do we have a lot of fun together yes
do you like to wrestle with me yes do i
when i come or do you like to jump on my
back yes
i said do you know i love you yes do you
know i love you a lot absolutely
i said great but i sometimes i know you
know yeah
and sometimes you guys do as well i
didn't mean it in a way for you to know
that i don't love you
you need to understand that part i
wanted to give you my interpretation of
the word annoying
you need to know you being born changed
my life
do you understand me yes daddy loves you
great i took him home you know why i did
that
i don't want that to linger because
words have so much weight behind them
i don't want that to linger and we went
home we had a great time we came back
out
there's certain words i refuse to accept
i made a video this week people got
pissed off posted on instagram
three four thousand comments within the
first couple hours posted on facebook a
bunch of different comments
here's my thoughts about this i can't
believe you said this why
i don't like another person imposing
their fears
insecurities and victimhood on me i'm
armenian i'm assyrian
every year we have the armenian and the
assyrian genocide
one and a half million armenians 500 000
assyrians i am
armenian and i'm a syrian these are
events that took place over 100 years
ago
with young turks on what they did what
the turkish empire
did to armenians one and a half million
people
and there are words that i see my
community use
where they say victims i can't listen to
that word because i don't see myself as
a victim
i don't it's too powerful of a word
i don't see myself as that so i'm not
going to say well we're victims
i'm sorry i'm not a victim i don't buy
that
so why am i saying this to you look i've
seen people change from good to bad
i've seen people change from good to bad
to dark places where i don't even
recognize them
i don't even know what happened to this
individual and i've seen people go from
dark places
to bad to good to great
the change from good to bad and the
change from bad to good
is both caused by words be very careful
with words you use you choose whatever
words you i'm just telling you some of
mine
the t word happens to be one of them i
don't like to use it
i talk about it openly with other people
and i'll use it obviously for the
example of this video i'm not giving the
whole word to you
but you know what the t word is i'm
tired i'm tired no
not going to use it for you when you're
done watching this video make a list of
certain words
that you use that don't serve you well
what are those words
your kids are listening to you your
siblings are listening to you your peers
are listening to you
do people work with you or listen to you
are those effective words
no stop using them add them to a list
and moving forward i don't want to use
these words
you use them once be aware not going to
use it again then
what words you want to add to your
repertoire what words you want to add to
your dictionary
start using those words and people
around you when they freely throw
words around stop them stop them don't
let them use it around you because the
form of unites not saying anything means
you're accepting those words
you don't have to accept those words you
can't say bobby i don't agree with that
mind so you can't believe it
totally fine it's america you have you
have the right to believe that
i'm just i'm not buying that so it's
going to stop right here you can buy
that i refuse to buy that
and then eventually people around you
are going to be like what is wrong with
you you sound a little weird
no no no i'm just being protective of my
spirit because however i feel
my family is going to feel and i don't
want them to have that kind of spirit in
my household
you get to decide that so my challenge
to you make a list of the words
and those that don't produce results
replace them with some good ones
and then go keep talking about it over
and over
and over again and watch yourself go
from wherever you are right now
to incredible places